you entered all the new technology oh if
you like the apples
I'm apps I'm checking I'm nothing if not
tech-savvy they have a new app I keep
after I say one thing it's not funny I
keep thinking this is gonna be last
maybe that's my problem
get to the joke first we can add laughs
later you can I've heard that before
no we won't we won't spend the money
[Laughter]
[Applause]
with a lukewarm reaction yeah you look
good this way this is good always borrow
some laughs from the basketball players
oh they got laughs that's right bring it
on Shaq yeah that's the way you want to
pick a fight yeah come on bring it on so
yeah and so they have an app now where
like it's in the winter and snowing and
you're like elderly you can turn the app
on and within five minutes someone will
come to your house and shovel your walk
that's nice or they will murder you with
a shovel shovel your walk I know you're
weak I know you're weak they know you're
weak the fine princess
[Laughter]
[Applause]
guy who takes a second to heat up but
when you do 20 minutes after you're gone
you're gonna be killed
he wrote a funny and a week-and-a-half
you're a history buff yeah that's that's
my space sorry oh yeah your history buff
through you like I like documentaries
that's what I watch it now do you like
documentary I'm crazy about Hitler I
can't I mean I don't like them
can't stop documentaries if I can't stop
watching it every documentary i watch
every weekend and you know Hitler's big
mistake the Nazis big mistake was the
goose-step I mean it's the mark the
crazy Marx they did nothing slows down a
blitzkrieg and you know this at 80% of
Nazis had hamstring issues the Nazis in
Argentina they go look at that
curmudgeon limping all right now listen
you I'd love to talk to you more but
we're staying longer we're sorry that
was really no no IIIi know what the
audience gets deathly silent all of a
sudden you would encounter this all the
time I know people after a sure they go
I laughed
that's always good boy I guess one you
did better than you think you did I like
the way I wave to nobody over there
that's my favorite you can see Andy
November 10th at the Oberon as part of
the Boston Comedy Festival your old
hunting stumping haunting stumping
graphics may sound like a serial killer
that's where you killed a couple of
people
we're called murders from the 80s in
Boston
you were the sniper back then with the
thing and the thing and the Son of Sam
please take that part out no no I loop
it that's my gift is that my gift that's
your vine all right
you seriously are one of the funniest
people we know Andy Kindler thank you
much for being over right back hey
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please